la guinée entame un nouveau chapitre de
son histoire mardi dernier vous le savez
un coup d'état militaire a mis fin au
régime qu'avait laissé en mourant après
25 ans de règne sékou touré le nouveau
président le colonel lansana veut
instaurer la démocratie et la libre
entreprise
les syndicats sont à nouveau autorisées
et tous les prisonniers politiques ont
été libérés
leurs familles ont organisé aujourd'hui
dans la capitale
une marche de soutien au nouveau régime
ce raisin de gatti de l' agence sipa
télévision ramène de conakry le premier
document filmé depuis le coup d'état
la paire d'essence total vivent en armes
et vive la république vive nos
libérateurs c'est tout ce que nous
entendons il est difficile amis
téléspectateurs
des cuivres ce mouvement de masse
spontanée dit salut le membre du comité
militaire de redressement national qui
est venu en son temps kevin ans honneur
qui avait nat 1 minute et cinq comités
dans qui a libéré notre peuple de vingt
six ans de dictature de 26 ans de 26 ans
de soumission aveugle de despotisme de
népotisme moi je dirais même le reporter
de la télévision guinéenne ne trouve
plus à cette souffle pour souligner
l'événement vie à sept jours exactement
la télévision officielle ne pouvait plus
assez de mots pour enterrer ahmed sekou
toure
le moment était venu pour le coup d'état
la mangue était mûr il ne s'agissait que
de la manger ainsi parle le colonel
diarra ici premier ministre du
gouvernement peu après l'annonce sur
radio conakry d'un coup d'état qui est
intervenu mardi ils sont dix-huit
nouveaux membres du gouvernement presque
tous des officiers formés en urss
le premier geste des nouveaux dirigeants
donnent le ton la libération des
prisonniers politiques détenus dans le
camp de boiro ce lieu d'internement et
est selon l'opposition un véritable camp
de concentration où sont morts des
dizaines de détenus politiques
la torture y était autorisé les
conditions de vie horrible plusieurs
prisonniers ils sont morts de faim le
gouvernement se propose d'édifier à
boire aux un monument à la mémoire des
martyrs de la justice cij en rétention
je ne peux pas vous dire tout ce qui est
ce bloc parce que nombre d'entre vous en
parce qu'il est n'est pas la commande de
nous avoir si intime que vous avez de me
sortir depuis quatre ans
je suis en prison le 16 juin 1986 et est
arrêté alors que j'étais venu pour dire
bonjour à mes parents et pour me
retremper dans mon pays d'origine
je suis venu de dakar je suis
fonctionnaire international
je travaille pour les nations unies
s'est fait 381 la simple raison kampala
et passer la nuit chez moi et m'ont dit
si tu es passé deux jours en jaune rien
de logique qui était au début de stage
on arrêtait complots contre le régime
l'an dernier on a même pas de 82 pour
des raisons que
j'ai comploté avec le ministre kapa
santé et le premier camarades qui a été
arrêté avant que je ne parte j'ai trouvé
que le camarade était complètement
instant t je suis un étudiant bon avant
que je ne parte j'ai trouvé au mans que
me confronter avec le camarade le
camarade était complètement instant t et
d'où le 29 décembre 1983 du camp boiro
alors lui calé son nom c'était sidiki
kaba un étudiant mnj tiers du contingent
libyen la population réclame à présent
justice pour les prisonniers disparus
deux premiers gestes de libération
succède à la déclaration qui dénoncent
la dictature sanglante et impitoyable de
ses coutures le comité militaire tient
quand même à souligner l'importance du
travail entrepris par l'ancien président
à l'extérieur du pays il est évident que
les nouveaux dirigeants veulent éviter
un clivage à l'intérieur leur programme
à présent instaurer une démocratie
véritable
évitant l'avenir toute dictature
personnelle
le résultat est immédiat les soldats
sortis des casernes eux n'auront pas
tiré un seul coup de feu
la mangue était mûr le complot couvait
depuis trois ans le chef d'état-major de
sékou touré devait être averti mais
avait refusé de participer
il fallait faire vite le coup d'état
était prévue pour samedi
mais mme harvey se réunissait le parti
unique afin de désigner le successeur de
sékou touré s'était donc mardi où jamais
il y avait trop de monde dans le secret
l'orientation principale du nouveau
régime est presque une profession de foi
non-alignés il espère avoir les
meilleures relations avec tous les pays
du monde
le nouveau gouvernement admet aussi la
critique pour ses lacunes ses
insuffisances et ses erreurs et cela
c'est nouveau
accalmie aujourd'hui